now you are a single is that correct
yeah unfortunately yeah why yeah what's
what's going on you're beautiful I'm
beautiful
Conan edit yeah beautiful famous and
you're such a nice person you just now
men know that you live in an apartment
with very thin walls yeah maybe we can
make some noise yeah no no no I don't
know what the problem is all right well
do you go on dates but you don't like
the guy what's happening you know why
it's I don't really date I don't think I
know honestly it's been so long for me
okay um I remember when Steve Harvey
yeah I'll call you out Steve Harvey
tried to hook me up at this one guy and
it's just awkward you know it was a
little awkward and I just said no which
I love rocking itself no and it didn't
work so I just said forget about it and
now I'm just I'm chillin I mean you got
some friends for me yes you did yeah you
know what it should do you should come
out with me some night we'll hit the
clubs why it wouldn't do people giggle
at that they kind of irregular at the
club no I would I would happily take you
out I'd introduce you to some people
sure your friends yeah or just random
people at the club
you got some friends and say yeah I'll
take you to the club nah yeah you could
come to a barbecue and meet some of the
homies like no yes first of all you'll
come to my house and I have a barbecue
for all the homies but then I insist
we're hitting the clubs you do that yeah
Empire Empire airs Wednesday nights at
8:00 on Fox and it's a giant smash
juggernaut hit
ta'rhonda jones I love talking to you I
love ya and seriously I will let's go
out that would be fun that's all right
that'd be really fun I'll be right back
comedian Aaron Jackson
you